monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues les désordres migratoires
actuels sont sans doute que les
prémisses de desésordres plus violents
de secous thélurique beaucoup beaucoup
plus violent qui sont à venir avec le
dérèglement climatique je l'ai entendu
tout à l'heure avec les dérèglements
géopolitiques et et avec aussi les
déséquilibres démographiques et
d'ailleurs dans le monde occidental
beaucoup beaucoup de gouver ement et de
droite et de gauche durcissent
considérablement leur législation
nationale le dernier en date ça a été
souligné c'est l'Allemagne c'est
Monsieur Scholz qui a présenté un projet
de loi il a d'ailleurs eu une
déclaration fracassante que je cite au
motamo en indiquant que il fallait
expulser à grande échelle les gens qui
n'ont pas le droit de rester en
Allemagne et Joe Biden vient de
poursuivre l'œuvre si j'ose dire de
Monsieur trupp puisque il a décidé la
continuation du mur
sur la frontière mexicaine je rappelle
simplement que Monsieur Biden est
démocrate et que Monsieur Olaf Scholz
est social-démocrate dans tous ces pays
et dans tous les pays d'Occident en
réalité la demande de fermeté elle vient
des classes populaire elle ne vient pas
des classes aisées qui ont les moyens de
se protéger des conséquences du désordre
migratoire en mettant leurs enfants dans
les bonnes écoles et en habitant les
beaux quartiers la réalité elle est là
monsieur le ministre il y a quelques
semaines vous aviez déclaré dans un
journal du dimanche que sur
l'immigration vous n'aviez aucun tableou
je ne demande qu'à vous croire sur
parole mais j'ai quelques doutes
pourquoi autant d'atterermoimement
pourquoi un accouchement aussi difficile
avec un texte tant de fois promis et un
texte tant de fois remis je pense au
contraire que pour votre majorité pour
votre majorité l'immigration reste un
tabou un tabou
d'abord sur le plan politique c'est le
en même temps qui débouche sur un double
jeu un tabou surtout sur le plan
numérique la question du nom qui est
fondamentale et un tabou sur le plan du
droit la question du droit qui est aussi
absolument essentiel d'abord le premier
tabout c'est la question du du nombre
tout nous y ramène tout nous y ramène
absolument parce que l'échec de
l'intégration vient du fait que on peut
intégrer des petits nombres des
individus mais comment intégrer des
populations qui souvent sont peu
désireuses d'adhérer à nos principes
républicains
et à nos modes de vie qui peut ici dire
de façon sérieuse qu'il n'y a pas de
lien entre tous ces échecs entre tous
ces échecs et l'insécurité qu'il n'y a
pas de lien entre tous ces échecs sur
l'intégration et la multiplication des
territoires perdus de la République
qu'elle soit légale ou illégale le
problème de l'immigration but sur la loi
des grand nombres c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous ne souhaitons pas cet
article 3 qui est devenu certes un peu
totéique mais je je voudrais y revenir
quelques instants d'abord parce que on
ne peut pas à la fois prétendre dans un
texte lutter contre l'immigration
illégale et ouvrir une brèche à
l'immigration illégale la fraude ne peut
pas être une voie de régularisation
parce que alors là on ouvre encore une
fois une facilité qui va créer un appel
d'air la deuxè la deuxème raison la
deuxème raison c'est que c'est une
formidable capitulation que aller
chercher une main d'œuvre bon marché
quand en France il nous faut encore
mobiliser une réserve extraordinaire de
travail qu'on mobilise pas au momentù je
vous parle il y a plus de 560000
étrangers qui eux sont en situation
régulière et qui sont au chômage au
moment où je vous parle il y a plus d'un
million de jeunes qui sont ni en emploi
ni à l'école 1900000 français qui sont
au RSA et 3 millions qui sont au chômage
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait qu'est-ce qu'on
en fait et j'ajoute et je termine
rapidement sur cet article 3 le travail
l'activité professionnelle n'est
absolument pas une condition qui permet
d'éviter une radicalisation je voudrais
citer l'attentat symboliquement de celui
qui avait été perpétré à rambouiller
Jamel gorchen il était en situation de
travail il était chauffeur livreur ce
que nous voulons nous c'est que le
pouvoir discrétionnaire du préfet
contrôle bien sûr l'activité réelle
professionnelle mais que on contrôle
dans ce pouvoir euh discrétionnaire
aussi la capacité des individus à
intégrer nos propres valeurs c'est ce
qui est fondamental et c'est ce qui nous
distingue de ce fameux article 3 il y a
aussi le tabou je le disais du droit
parce que nous avons depuis des années
et des années abandonné les instruments
juridique qui nous permettent de réguler
l'immigration et tout ça débouche sur
une impuissance extraordinaire une
impuissance coupable que les Français
constatent à chaque fait divers qui n'en
sont plus des faits divers bien bien
évidemment cette impuissance elle était
organisée d'abord par le législateur qui
a multiplié les protections les
exceptions à la règle et les exceptions
ont tué la règle et la règle peut tuer
des Français on l'a vu à Ar ras bien sûr
si c individus caucasien avait été
expulsé le professeur Dominique Bernard
serait toujours en vie bien évidemment
et qu'importe sil s'il est arrivé en
France avant son âge avant l'âge de de
13 ans nous ce que nous voulons ça n'est
pas multiplier les exceptions aux
exceptions ce que vous nous proposez ce
que nous voulons nous c'est anéantir les
exceptions pour que il y ait la règle
vis-à-vis des expulsions et vis-à-vis
des eqtf et que enfin on puisse aussi
rétablir ce que Hollande avait dé faits
c'est-à-dire le délu pour séjours
irrégulierers pour bien marquer que un
pays une nation une communauté nationale
un corps politique c'est un dedans et un
dehors tout simplement pour ce qui
concerne c'est impuiss je voudrais
revenir un instant sur un certain nombre
de jurisprudence qui sont choquantes
surtout lorsqu'elles font
systématiquement en tout cas parfois
prévaloir les droits individuels la
protection des droits individuels sur
l'intérêt général sur un cadre collectif
sur le besoin d'un peuple de se protéger
je pourrais prendre plein d'exemples je
vais prendre des exemples que vous
connaissez bien la condamnation par la
CEDH de la France à la suite de
l'expulsion de deux chetchînes
radicalisé comme vous le savez et
dangereux et là
nous sommes condamnés parce que
l'expulsion de ces individus encore une
fois dangereux ne permettait pas d'avoir
une garantie suffisante qu'ils éent dans
leur propre pays d'origine un procès
équitable mais qu'est-ce qu'il fallait
faire protéger les Français ou protéger
ces individus dangereux vous avez
répondu d'ailleurs vous avez dit moi je
préfère payer l'amende et vous avez bien
fait monsieur le ministre vous voyez ce
que je veux dire par là c'est que il
faut trouver monsieur le rapporteur un
juste équilibre entre les État de droit
qui respecte les textes qui n'interprète
pas dans des interprétations très
créatives les traités et la démocratie
la souveraineté populaire retourner les
droits individuels systématiquement
contre la souveraineté populaire ça
n'est pas l'état de droit ça n'est plus
l'état de droit évidemment c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous voulons ce
référendum une révision de la
Constitution pour rendre aux Français
cette capacité à décider par eux-même la
politique migratoire Françis française
président de la République a fait un pas
il y a loin de la coupe aux lèvres on
n'est pas des perdre de l'année le
président du Sénat n'est plus là en tout
cas moi je ne suis plus un perd de
l'année et et nous attendrons de voir ce
qu'il advient de cette révision
constitutionnelle le le tabou politique
un un mot simplement sur le le en même
temps je disais que c'était un double
jeu parce que il y a un non dit dans
dans ce texte c'est le contexte de son
élaboration il il a fallu que vous soyez
écartelé entre une aile droite et une
aile gauche le problème c'est que en
même temps en matière migratoire ça ne
marche pas parce que les signaux que
vous allez envoyer au monde entier et
que vont très bien percevoir les
filières ce doit être un signal de
grande fermeté tout l'axisme sera
interprété comme un appel d'air et vous
savez que en France nous avons des
appels d'air on aura l'occasion d'y
revenir en matière en matière de
regroupement familial et cetera un
ouvrage un ouvrage un ouvrage été rédigé
par quelqu'un qui connaît très bien ces
choseslà et qui s'appelle Didier leski
et qui ne vient pas d'ailleurs de euh
d'une sucursale de la droite pour
terminer pour conclure monsieur le
ministre pour terminer pour terminer et
conclure je crois
que je pense que l'UR est grave parce
que on voit bien que jamais les risques
les menaces euh de partition que les
menaces de fragmentation communautaire
non'ont autant fragiliser l'unité
française et nous en sommes parfaitement
conscients c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous nous abandonnerons ni aux postures
de ceux qui pourraient se contenter du
yakafucon ou alors d'expédient de slogan
mais on se contentera pas non plus de
l'imposture de ceux qui qui appellent
l'ambiguïé qui appellent les demi-mesure
qui appelle finalement le en même temps
nous voulons un texte efficace et nous
voulons un texte utile on verra on
commence l'examen de ce texte ou bien ce
texte donne les conditions et nous
ferons des propositions des nombreuses
propositions d'amendement
ou bien ces propositions sont reprises
ou bien on durcit le texte ou bien on a
la conviction intime d'aller dans le
sens supérieur de la nation parce que
les français demandent cette fermeté et
les Français d'abord encore une fois
d'en bas pas les Français d'en haut bien
et alors nous pourrons voter le texte si
en revanche si en revanche nous sommes
persuadés qu'il y a une ambigué qui
subsiste nous ne tricherons pas nous ne
jouerons pas les faux semblants et nous
nous opposerons à ce texte voilà notre
position elle est claire elle est très
très simple elle consiste à dire la
vérité au français et je pense que cet
enjeu il est énorme il est finalement si
je devais réduire en quelques mots de
faire en sorte que demain la République
soit partout chez elle en France merci
de votre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attention